Hales going for us my name is Pippa and
today I'm joined with the very special
desk
clap it up everyone four and got where
the [ __ ] did he go hey how's it going
bros my name is Ben and welcome to the
very special guest
Edgar goddammit bleep dirty a guy dirty
yeah yeah shut the [ __ ] up Felix now
let's begin today's video there's a
reason I have Edgar as a guest here
today because today's theme is respect
Thank You Marco play respect not just
any form of respect but respect women
it's become a meme on the internet to
respect women usually it looks like this
we have a subject we have an item or an
action and then we have a whamon and
it's usually pretty hard horrible to see
respecting women is no joke it is no
joke
to joke about that cat needs those pills
and so does women need respect edgar is
still a teenager I need to teach him how
to properly respect women and not like
all these stupid memes are you put are
you paying attention Edgar oh yes cool
well let's do this let's begin with wiki
ha how to treat the woman being number
one being a good communicator well yeah
if you have to whisper
then I doubt you're a good communicator
what the [ __ ] are you saying
I bet he's saying something sexist be a
good listener ask her how she's feeling
fight fair
but most of all
show respect this is me when I respect
women if you ever see me do this that
means I am currently respecting women
what about you guys but I got a lot of
respect for women
one day Edgar my son you will be able to
respect women just as well as I do
are you listening all right he's paying
close attention behave like a gentleman
treat her fairly don't open doors this
just shows you think she's waiting you
don't open the doors for the women that
just makes I think she's wait you gotta
let her open her own door so she knows
she is strong enough to open that door
herself if there's a man you open that
door for him if there's a whamon you she
best open her own [ __ ] doors there's
no way you can be polite and open the
doors let her up a little goddamn door
but what if I just want to be polite
this doesn't matter now Edgar is 3 years
old
isn't that right Edgar oh yeah which
basically means he is 13 in dog years
what yes that is exactly how that works
shut the [ __ ] up so we're going to watch
a video that helped me as a young 13 or
a boy really shaped my way of looking at
women and respecting women I didn't go
from this to this in just a day
respecting women takes time patience
skill motivation here we go here we go
dear thirteen-year-old boys yes don't
ask a girl after time of the month
that's right okay have you you best not
ask but I can't speak good keep it that
way
yeah but what if she is super hot I
don't know actually about that one that
wasn't that I mean of course not what
are you you got no respect for women
don't don't you dare ever ever sliding
to a girls teams because if you do that
means you don't respect women if you
have a slide in my DMS
you best be sure you have respect for me
because if you don't have respect for me
you don't have respect for the women
dear thirteen-year-old boys stop wearing
so much Nike sports good guy what are
you doing are you never wear Nike
Sportswear that's right that's right
think about that one yeah that's right
yeah you shame much shame shame Edgar
dear 13 year old boys don't act like a
big huge jerk when a girl says she
doesn't want to go out with you oh did
you hear that I like her face when she
does that one cuz it's like boys it's a
good finish it's a good fit what do you
agree with you dear 13 year olds voice
it's okay to have acne that's right and
if you don't have acne you are
disrespecting women and you need to
rethink what you're doing with your
facial construction wait what what
liking musical theater that's that's
more gaming like in anime and manga dude
if you like anime and manga what a
[ __ ] nerd it's super gay dude you
like theater what are you what are you
utilize musical theater that's super gay
isn't that right Edgar
but I love musical theater shut the [ __ ]
up you're not my son
I'm kidding I love you I love you dear
13 year old boys don't put your hair up
- Jesus what the [ __ ] does that mean
nope you can't make me choose between
women and Jesus it's Jesus every time if
I want to quest my hair up to Jesus I
can do it and so can you Edgar listen
here boy don't listen to this women
that's right I'll quit my hair all I
want to Jazz's I'm quitting too Jessie's
right now guys and I'm respecting when
dear thirteen-year-old boys it's okay to
not have muscles it's okay to not have
abs it's okay to not love yourself are
you saying it's okay not to have these
big bad boys are you saying it's okay
not to have this super abs and it's okay
not to love yourself
[Music]
all right I think we learned a lot here
today about respecting women isn't that
right Edgar thank you thank you anger
respecting women it's not a joke okay
and I want you every one day everyone to
follow my lead and give me your best
respecting women post right now as
you're watching and also I this is
really important to me because to say I
know the solo joke with the hair and all
but this is very important to me I it's
something I wanted to do for a very long
time I I just never really got the time
to do it properly I really want to
change the brofist I find it to be
offensive insensitive and a
microaggression
the brofist is so heavily mailed
structured and pandering to men when we
really need to just focus more on
respecting women so I want to change the
brofist to something else I've given
this a lot of thought it's an iconic
moment in this channel history but we're
changing the brofist into something
gender-neutral something that anyone no
matter who you are can get on board with
I'm wanting to call it this is fist sis
fist respect women fist that's it
respect women respecting women one punch
at a time that was a bad joke I'm sorry
don't don't hit women but don't hit guys
too
there's one more video by 3d movies for
you legend absolute legend this guy
taught me everything I know about women
he taught me how to respect women as you
can tell he's an old man so he knows
what he's talking about that's how it
works and when I date a woman mm-hmm I
don't go over and open up the door for a
woman
I see [ __ ] see this command knows you
don't open up the door for women because
they need to feel strong I treat her
like crap are you telling me women can
respect the man no that's impossible
how could this be I've been fed a lie
all this day 3d movies for you what else
knowledge do you have for us you know
I've been through the opening the car
door and argue whether she's dumb what
you know treat her like crap just punch
your lady they love that one tough guys
they don't want little fairy wimps that
open the car door for him and treat him
with respect
they want to be treated like a Betty I
need to write a restaurant themselves I
need you to pull out their chair just
anyone have a paper Betty I need to [ __ ]
my buddy okay I got it tough guy so
treat him like crap given what they want
babies don't you get it
I guess nice
look I've been around the block a few
times okay I don't know probably like
six psilocin vaginas
48 women in my life
48 18 1848 this man is a living sex
machine 48 women egg you know am i I
might have done this women thing wrong
maybe this 3d movies for you man is
right after all I've never had a 10 for
the mustache like that boy how come you
never had a 10th
I don't get it I don't get it at all man
dude you marry if you marry a really
good-looking sexy woman she might cheat
on you mother I think we learned a lot
about respecting whamming here today
boys and and girls and girls especially
especially girls is wrist video do I
have any girls watching this video if
you are then let me tell you okay you
you finish this video you say something
good let me put on some nice music
[Music]
hi
my name is Alex and this is my dodge
anger
we respect women do you respect women as
well then please leave a like in this
video that would release every light
equals one respect of a whamon if this
video doesn't get 10,000 likes it get
will never appear on this channel again
because I will export him to a
third-world country where he will learn
how to respect them properly
thank you all for respecting women and
as always
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
have fun come on tough guy not bad do
you think you could take me out huh